Speaker 1: Let's get to some callers and see
what is on the minds of the great people in our
audience. We do this now via discord. You can find
and join the discord at David Pakman dot com slash
discord. Why don't we start today with Harpur
from South Carolina. Harpur, you were on the air.
Speaker 2: Hey, David. So I was just wondering,
I saw your episode on Tuesday about how you know.
Fox is kind of changing their tone a little bit,
and then I saw today, I saw actually
Sean Hannity, I don't know when it was
basically just urging people watching to get the
vaccine, the search and that sort of thing. Do
you think that's actually going to be effective?
Because I feel like that's probably one of the
most effective things that could could be done.
Speaker 1: I do. Now, I want to make one
caveat here. Add one caveat, which is even as
we've seen Fox over the last 72 hours become
much more pro vaccine, there's still a bunch of
anti vaccine stuff happening on the channel. But
you're completely right and we've covered that.
There seems to be overall a different tone.
I think it will make a big impact when people
people take advice from people they trust.
And as sad as it is, there's millions of people in
this country that trust Fox News and nobody else.
And so I hope it makes a difference. I just want
people to get vaccinated. Why this is happening,
I don't know. One one thought was that there's
like a lawsuit concern that's motivating this.
Another one is it was claimed that there have been
discussions between the Biden White House and Fox
News and that that whatever was discussed is the
explanation for the change from Fox News, although
FOX News has denied that, you know, the cynical me
says did did the White House make some promises to
Fox about Biden interviews or events if they
help with vaccination? I don't know. I don't
know. But whatever it is, as much pro vaccine
stuff as Fox is willing to do, I'm with it.
Speaker 2: Yeah, I also saw Biden talking
about how Facebook is killing people and
allowing all this disinformation, I feel like the
administration is actually cracking down on stuff
now once they didn't reach their July 4th goal.
Yeah, they're actually they're actually trying
a little more now, which is great. Yeah.
Speaker 1: So, you know, I can't tell you
exactly why it happened, but I'm glad
that it's a change that we're seeing.
Speaker 2: Yeah, I also had a brief question, kind
of totally different. I'm also a drummer. Do you
have any tips that are like any good cymbals
or gear that you like, that you think people
that are drummers should check out?
Speaker 1: I love like the extra special
outrageously dry ride from Silja and I don't
know what it's actually called, but it's one
this one has like no shine on it whatsoever. I
just think it's such a great jazz ride. That's a
that's one of my favorite pieces of equipment.
Speaker 2: Yeah, I've I have a really good a
mile ride that's pretty dry. I
like a good dry ride. Oh yeah.
Speaker 1: Thank you. My pleasure.
All right. Harpur from South Carolina.
Great to hear from you. Really a perfect
series of questions I have to tell you.